so you can
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
yo what's up guys I am Thomas dopasiola
whatever you want to call me this is the
dope usual podcast my co-host over here
Marty O'Neal what's up folks what's up
guys guys I'm just telling Marty like I
don't think I smoke today it's a rare
day for me man guys special guest today
you guys already know we've been hyping
it up we've been talking about it
introducing Steelo Brim thank you for
being here man my guys appreciate it
thanks for having me man appreciate you
being here you know what I'm saying all
that knows I got an alert on my
Instagram that was like yo the dope as
usual podcast I want you to pull up I'm
like oh [ __ ] what's this I want the yard
sales all these do seem cool I'm gonna
definitely show some love you know what
I'm saying I'm pretty sure man of course
man appreciate it man and once again
you're one we've had what 50 guests your
most punctual person
I'm texting you I'm on the way
just appreciate being considerate in
terms of just communication almost
[ __ ] producer on television man yeah
like I don't play that [ __ ] you know
what I'm saying like I'm very punctual
with all my business everything I do so
for me I may smoke all day but I'ma
still
always appreciate you man of course man
so right off the bat real quick Marty I
I just want to get into this because uh
Marty because I well I know we'll be
like 40 minutes in and go Marty we
didn't even talk about it Marty's had a
long long
journey into this right here okay yeah
all right so if you want to break down
your thing real quick
no this is just this is a big episode
for me just because I go way back with
the whole Camp okay okay all right so
I'm out of Buffalo okay I've been out
here for about 10 years now but I was
like a recording artist out of Buffalo
my guys Graphics all that eight mile
came up moved out here yeah yeah DJ ski
all that type of [ __ ] got into
podcasting real happy but when I was in
Buffalo one of my big
one of my big plays I was trying to get
a Dr Dre record deal and I was trying to
get over Rob Dyrdek that was my real big
things those that those things are very
different those are game changers
you imagine coming down being like my
goal is to be signed to Dr Dre and Rob
dyrd yeah well because I had my whole
graphic design thing going too so yeah
yeah all right so the the long and short
of it is Rob had a little brand that he
was doing back in the day called make
your own luck okay okay and he had a
contest the T-shirt contest that he was
doing for it so I did a t-shirt make
your own luck and submitted it but I did
a theme song for it too I shot a music
video I did a song make your own luck
put it out Rob favored it on his Twitter
I was like damn this is it I'm lit I'm
not here so not then I just went on a
little campaign and really trying to get
his attention and uh calling around
getting people on the phone trying to
just make that happen middle you know
what I mean a whole big campaign ended
up out here anyway but what you mean
anyway did you meet him did you did you
get them or anything no not technically
I did get inside listen I used to you
didn't make your own look I'm sure you
were here today aren't we yo Marty Marty
uh will find your grandma's best
friend's phone number he used to be in
collections so he'd be like I got robbed
your dick I got a big cat on the phone
did you yeah okay yeah I was out there
trying to do what I could back yeah
yeah he was cool he's like who's this
I'm like bro don't worry about it listen
I got you this press kit I got a song I
mean I'll make my own luck right now
yeah yeah and he was like okay cool I'm
sorry you didn't meet him but at least
you're here though you know what I'm
saying me doing this it's full circle
I'm kind of here so you kind of meet
them a little bit I was just with them
earlier you know what I'm saying but you
were a part of that whole that whole era
that I mean yeah I mean I came in a
little later obviously I was a huge
Robin big fan like like all of us but uh
Fantasy Factory I got to uh hit the tail
end of it you know what I'm saying I got
to be in the last two or three seasons
of fantasy factory so that was pretty
cool you know for me at least it's like
being a fan coming full circle I was on
I'm actually doing uh publishing and
production helping drama who's Rob's
cousin with music so I was um kind of
running his whole Music Company back
then doing this oh I used to a r so
that's why my background is music and
then from there I transitioned to
different things yeah but um Robin met
me at the studio just randomly from me
yeah just for me working and he thought
it was funny it was like yo we should do
a show together yeah and I thought he
was just bullshitting obviously and I
was like yeah cool man good story bro uh
and then literally we talked about it
for a few and then did not have his
number had not talked to him again since
then he called me three months later I
was like hey hey they'll give you a real
impersonation it's how you call us every
time yeah
yeah this is Rob you know who it is and
I'm like dude stop it on my phone what's
up but at that time I did not notice how
he calls I didn't even know him so I was
like yeah it's this Rob I'm like man
stop playing me a hang up thinking
somebody [ __ ] in my phone so he
calls back like no serious this is Rob
oh what's up I was like oh what's up he
was like that show that I mentioned uh
three months ago we started filming it
tomorrow can you be there and I was I
guess the rest is history you know we
started from the show next day 10 a.m I
was there and uh now we've been doing it
for 11 years and around 1100 episodes
almost to the day right yeah yeah
something uh I don't oh they did that
research
and then we actually aired we might be
like around like August 22nd 29th 29th
yeah yeah some [ __ ] like that yeah but
we had filmed that I believe
um
not a whole year but like maybe like six
months before we even aired then oh
really yes we've been doing it for a
minute now a good little minute now
that's dope dude just real quick for the
music thing like I said you should be an
Anar he told me something Marty's such
such good so good at research man he
pulls it up and he goes you know Larry
junago why are you bringing up Larry
June in this conversation right now yeah
I had no idea that you did music first
off man yeah I didn't know that my homie
ratchet man you probably know ratchet
man um he's good homies with Larry June
so I've been following this guy's
progress for so long yeah and you got
music it's one of my favorite artists
bro some of the smoothest [ __ ] comes
survival man that's my god dude that's
my dog yeah shout out to Uncle Larry
yeah so you're coming out with something
with him I got a single coming out yo uh
on September 9th with Larry June so
that's next week next Friday so that
should be summer goodbye yes summer
goodbye my guy you already know it's
gonna be it's gonna be definitely
interesting I dropped the full project
uh as you know like I just said I've
been doing music for a minute I worked
in the a r field and and as I just Dove
back into music this time around I was
like you know what whatever what would
it be like if I dove into the artist
side of it you know how would that look
and I've kind of always wanted to do
that a little bit and I'm all about
dreaming you know what I'm saying I'm
all about I hate people trying to
project on you and tell you the
different things you can't do just
because they afraid they'll feel like oh
no you can't me on that TV show you
can't you can't rap or no you you can't
make a fashion line because you do this
other thing you like who the [ __ ] are
you I could do whatever I want to do
what I'm supposed to do yeah yeah for
sure if that's who you are that's your
DNA we are multi-layered as we know we
all are definitely multi-layer so for me
it was a a time for me to be like you
know what don't be afraid you know Tyler
don't be afraid to be good at different
things either you know what I'm saying
because because it scares people
sometimes sometimes it's intimidating if
you're decent and as I'm just starting
uh I think I'm getting better but yeah
me and Larry got a record on the way
next Friday it's gonna be it's gonna be
nice that's cool working everybody hear
that at uh it'd be everywhere you know
on your Spotify Spotify yeah apple yeah
it'd be everywhere you release it under
your own name
that's right my question
yeah anybody's saying anything otherwise
doesn't understand what it is to be like
an artist yeah to have it's I say it all
the time it's the same muscle it extends
into different things yes different
creators you're good you said right you
got yours yeah just because I'd be so in
my hair what do you smoke
I'll tell you why I'm a waste not that
I'll give you my real reason so uh
because I didn't stop smoking until I
was 29 years old so for me so for me
it's like I'm Louise not because I
already have money if I'm being real
with you so the different type of I go
to the studio you know as I'm working
with people in music and shower work we
have the homies again I used to ain't
been knowing [ __ ] for forever [ __ ]
knew I didn't smoke now I might smoke
with [ __ ] and I'd be a buck with you
sometimes I get cloudy get cloudy as a
[ __ ] because we smoking
different [ __ ] my [ __ ] is probably a
little cleaner a little this and [ __ ]
just like I got packs I'm like I respect
your pack fam love to your pack but I
cannot smoke necessarily
cloudy as [ __ ] is anybody being strong
is it should make you feel different I
don't know if it's what do you smoke you
could go to a certain street I'm hybrid
yeah yeah people people smoking a la la
la where's my East Coast smoking and
[ __ ] we straight indicus we straight
slumping your seat we straight melting
the couch that's not necessarily my swag
I do too much business throughout the
day and for me if I smoke that I'm done
so I gotta keep going keep moving so I
like that man come on you know I'm
trying to cater yourself cater to so at
least make yourself smoking all he
smokes is the heaviest thing but
I am tired I run mad businesses so I am
tired yeah and I smoke hash rosin all
day so I get it but I think it's just
the life of being a [ __ ] drug dealer
and [ __ ] smoking weed my whole life
every all day every day my tolerance is
through the [ __ ] roof I think is what
it is yeah no no it's definitely that
you want a joint yeah I can tell cause
the grinder yeah it's like for me I call
myself a casual chronosaur because
anything I do I I do it to a certain
level I do it but I don't ever try to
come off as an expert any of this [ __ ] I
got hella sneakers people might be like
you a sneak ahead I'm like absolutely no
shoes yeah I like shoes they cool people
like are you are you are you a weed
expert absolutely not first of all I'm
too late in the game guys I'm too late
in the game I do enjoy it for sure
people know that I'm gonna come around
here like you probably got some tree on
him but but at the same time now I ain't
the craziest at all I'd say people like
do you I'll smoke him I'm like probably
not
it's not a competition
however you feel because I like this I
like waking up
having my little joint smoking my you
know what I mean like it's not about
abundance anymore like it used to be
when I wake up and smoke a zip because
I'm [ __ ] bored yeah no you know it's
not the same man
you know what I'm saying it's like
coffee for me like I kind of it's
basically damned me the same thing as
coffee for me like me too I wake up I
wake and break for sure I get right into
it but yeah you hate yourself because
then you don't eat yourself because you
don't necessarily eat a [ __ ]
breakfast and then you like fam why be
doing this to myself every day I'm just
eating joints this is crazy
yo that's exactly what I say in the
morning pieces piece of [ __ ] yeah as I'm
taking a dab and making my Hunger go
away most people think it's the opposite
it's definitely not I know it's making
your hunger go away from you she goes
away within around three or two you're
like [ __ ] well I make that Hunger Games
that is a Health Choice I think I'm
doing healthy uh fasting and [ __ ] nah
see I think we supposed to be easy more
speed that metabolism up you know what
I'm saying we slowing it down so you
know what's up for real because that's
exactly how it sounds right yeah for
sure
it's the worst like you only drink no
water I got on my phone for two hours
what am I doing but if you wake up with
that hangover it's secure real quick oh
yeah yeah you hit that joint real quick
you like [ __ ] I'm back to life I just
read the bongs I gotta be honest that's
my [ __ ] see I can't see again this is
when we started being an expert this is
when I started saluting you from afar
and say hey man respect keep it away
from me man I don't want to get hit that
hard yeah I only I had a bong I think I
I bought a bong I was like you know what
[ __ ] I'm about bong my boy challenged me
about you gotta get the bomb man you
don't like it's a cleaner it's a clean
smoker you gotta say you only need a
little bit of weed all right cool my
chest was on fire for like a [ __ ] day
fam I said I'm not smoking this [ __ ] no
more I'm too old for these decisions
I'm giving somebody else this ball I
think the next [ __ ] that walked in my
house I'm like you smoke family with
this ball yeah my Rick and Morty bomb it
was cool oh I know exactly which Bond
you're talking about my homie makes that
bong a little patterns all over it the
little Rick and Morty's all over it yeah
yeah homie makes that
that's awesome
all right so uh real quick all right
later June September 9th yeah
my bad go Marty well I was just gonna
say to that same point the first thing
on your Instagram bio is Art collector
yeah so where do you stand with that
what do I stand with that I collect art
I mean you buy a canvas no that's what
you're doing uh no I'm buying I'm by Art
I collect R for real that's one thing I
[ __ ] do for real for real like I um I
would say I'm in the space seriously uh
it's something that I could see myself
doing for the rest of my life uh it's
something I uh truly enjoyed to to
invest back into
um all Arts but specifically Black Arts
a lot you know I'm saying I try to like
you know
there's a lot of black artists have
black empowerment are not necessarily
black empowerment may just be black
artists you know what I'm saying
sometimes it's just about supporting the
actual artists because myself some
Mexican kid doing some [ __ ] like hey
yeah all right maybe I'll help you out
no I'm not even maybe you should you
know it's different like when you see
when you see your own you know the
different things they've been through
you know the struggle also through the
actual um canvas through the actual
storytelling of the artist through the
message a lot of times it's it's a
connectivity there there's there's a
connection that you have with that as a
Mexican man you see it's a Latino or you
might see a Mexican dude perfect [ __ ]
you like [ __ ] you don't get this
this is for me and mine so I just try to
make sure I'm investing back because
it's not necessarily everybody's job to
understand the stories of my people it's
my job though to if I can to invest back
in those stories it's my job to to
understand them so I definitely [ __ ]
collect our but I collect a whole bunch
of I own white R2 what's up
no I found somebody recently on Twitter
the reason I asked
um he's uh very very
het leans heavy toward like the black
Power And Black Pride art his name's
duga duga are I just found him this fool
is going off I just bought a painting
off his ass I can't wait for it to show
up I'll show you it after please do yo
this motherfucker's Throne like New York
uh grills gold teeth from the south on
top of like African face paintings it is
the hardest [ __ ] I've ever [ __ ] seen
in my life all hyper realism I gotta see
it uh I'll show you I'll show you it
dude he's he's rushing it dude do you
get into like uh digital art nfts and
stuff too
uh I I hosted the actual coinbase thing
at a complexcon this past year it was an
nft thing I have nothing against nfts uh
as I'll with anything else I just want
to see how the market settles I want to
see exactly where they land right now
what I can say is that throughout time
the one thing we know is that
the art that is there the art that is
paintings the art that our sculptures is
tangible art the things that you can
actually touch and and you know kind of
where that market is versus the nft I
don't know it's a cool way for [ __ ] to
clean money I don't know but I don't I
don't know if it's necessarily uh how
real it is I think the people who will
thrive in the space are people who are
only specifically in the NFC space
they're not trying to do both I think
that like if you can find a way to be
you know uh Innovative or a proprietary
in that market and you're like oh we're
just we're just doing this thing and
this is where the [ __ ] my face is if
you're the Banksy of just nfts and
you're not doing Banksy work and trying
to do nfts I think that's what you'll
probably do best but I don't uh
necessarily own that many nfts I own
some but they've been mostly gifted to
me when you go to buy print art as an
investment yeah like how is there's got
to be channels that you go through
because like at one point does it become
valuable as an investment I'm just art
you see anywhere it's all it's all
channels you know it's all about
Galleries and stuff you know then the
galleries kind of dictate
um Market the market they can't dictate
the artists and and yeah whether you
touch it you can go try to buy a piece
of art from an artist that you know if
he's dealing with the gallery he
probably has to to charge you something
close to the same amount or else he's
undercutting the gallery and that's bad
business for the gallery so I mean it's
a whole bunch of channels
um it's a whole bunch of ways of getting
there you know what I'm saying I'm
guessing it's a lot about networking I'm
guessing it's a lot about brushing you
know those shows with the right people
but yeah I've been blessed enough to say
I've kind of always been that way you
know what I'm saying if I'm gonna put me
in a room I can I can work that room and
people feel like I'm authentic so I'm
sorry
I want to speak for him but yeah I feel
that way I feel like he probably saw me
and was like yo something real about you
I don't [ __ ] know what it is but
maybe it's something really about you
and you know as time went on I guess it
worked and we both that's my that's my
dog for Life honestly you know obviously
you know you don't see people stick
together for 12 13 14 years not often
bro not often no no no I mean that's I
mean that's a test all of us the
camaraderie we all have and just being
able to work together but yeah it's a
fun environment you know what I'm saying
with the watch videos and [ __ ] talk all
day so like I come in there with good
energy and I talk my [ __ ] you know what
I'm saying hopefully it makes it on the
show if it don't I'm still good [ __ ] out
all day all right all right you want to
keep in the gyms uh yeah I mean early on
we were joking me and Rob would joke Rob
even tell you something he needs to he
would say they would just take my jokes
my laughs and they would just use them
for him and they would though that would
be true that would be true it's like if
you come to a live taping like we're
talking way more we're talking hella
[ __ ] Rob's talking hella [ __ ] I'm
talking about this damn near a podcast
really uh yeah I mean
it's definitely a free-flowing thing we
like now we've got into such autopilot
that we we shoot if if on television is
a 20 22 minute episode we can shoot that
actual episode in 28 minutes
yeah so now we're just keeping
everything now now and more of the last
I'll say five six years but before it
used to be like we would film for an
hour and then they you know obviously
chopped that down
so how does it feel man to be this
generation is America's Funniest Home
Videos
because that's honestly that's honestly
it's just it's it's it's the Next
Generation stay alone bro hold on hold
on once Bob Saget was gone in those
first couple years after I would say
America's Funniest Home Videos was no
longer raining you know real TV Spike TV
came out they were showing all the clips
on police chase wow that's when the
earth started changing like
yo I can see cops [ __ ] chasing people
you know not just cops every watch 30
Cop episodes one episodes they were
really chasing somebody yeah but you
know America's craziest uh police chases
that [ __ ] changed it yeah I mean I feel
like it feels good obviously to be able
to [ __ ] yeah I think you know when we
that's all said and then we'll be able
to look back and really enjoy what we
built because you know
right now yeah I have moments where I'm
like damn that's dope but like it I
don't know if it's necessarily really
hit me we filmed we have filmed and I'm
gonna say this because I'm gonna talk my
[ __ ] for two seconds we have films
[ __ ] 1100 episodes of Television it's
just not heard of like many most shows
are trying to get to season two or three
and back like desperately we're in
season 30. we're in season 30 right now
like 30 30. we're in season 30 and we
film and we're filming right now 42
episodes per season so like we're
pumping out television and it's for me
if nothing else it's fun people watch
the show and they'd be like yo fam I'll
be a buck with you I got homies that did
real life beers they'd be like [ __ ] you
don't even get it you help me get
through my beard fam like you know [ __ ]
locked up that's that's one of the only
things they keep on I'm like work work
and now I start realizing like yeah of
course it's a positive ass show it's
just funny video ain't no political
nothing in this [ __ ] can't get into it
real quick over no [ __ ] it's like yo
turn on videos you keep it keep it on
mute if you want to yeah if you want to
turn it on great great turn that [ __ ] on
listen let's just talk [ __ ] and you like
you know what this is fun and
free-flowing I think I think you know
during the pandemic a lot of people say
yo when we was locked in our crib you I
hope that's a whole bunch too so like I
enjoy the fact that we also contribute
somewhat to [ __ ] happiness this is
it's a cool part of life man you know
yeah putting out Good Vibes every time
you put out an episode that's what I
love about our show too I just love
people going yo you make my day my
Mondays I'm super [ __ ] stoked because
I know I'm about to see another episode
we always compare it to did you watch
The Simpsons as a kid of course all
right so you remember on Sunday night
after football and [ __ ] The Simpsons
would start that feeling you got like oh
[ __ ] yeah I know I got school tomorrow
but I got 30 minutes of The Simpsons
maybe Malcolm in the Middle tonight
that's the feeling we always try to give
people like oh [ __ ] it's Monday I got
four more days of work but this [ __ ]
show is coming on today so that's that's
what people you guys are giving people
especially in the jails I [ __ ] get it
why is this [ __ ] I get it because my
homie said I'll watch Malcolm Mill every
day in prison it's my favorite show yeah
I have homies that got out of prison
like yo Judge Judy I watch her every day
I know her it's because you know it's
Public Access it's it's like the [ __ ]
they show everybody on TV yeah it's it's
tight
all right here we go
roll another joint that's I don't think
I've ever had anybody in the show just
roll joints I'm glad to hear you say
that though because I always wondered
like because you're saying it's
free-flowing it's a conversation we bang
it out we're just kind of talking like
you it seems so it seems like it'd be
all not scripted but like it wouldn't be
so free-flowing but I guess you guys
have known each other for so long it's
like well I mean it's interesting like
it's funny like we've had people who
like do really well on YouTube and like
in the YouTube space who you know
obviously in the YouTube space you can
edit as much as you want to uh and
they'll come on our show because they're
big at YouTube and they'll do horribly
because they don't get that is
we are not taking any breaks we're not
asking you any like so it's just like
yeah oh you didn't get your jokes in
it's over with I'm sorry we're going
back because we filmed six episodes a
day so right after you're like we could
have we could have another like we could
be doing your episodes and you're like
damn that was it and we're like we're
already going to the back to get dressed
for the next episode
[Music]
way more famous than me right now I I
that I thought it was a cartoon bro I
should look like an edited photo I gotta
be honest you know what I'm very sorry
that happened to you A lot of people
told me that I thought it was fake a lot
of people said that people were like the
only reason I think that Instagram not
taking this photo down is because people
think it's fake they think it's a
cartoon look like a rubber foot and I'm
like and that and I read and go
it's actually dislocated it didn't break
it though I had no break no no no actual
ligament damage no tears no surgery no
anything I actually don't even need
rehab God is good I legitimately only at
a dislocation it's called a table
dislocation it's when your whole foot
dislocate from your [ __ ] leg which
don't even sound I guess you'd be able
to do and your [ __ ] just moving around
and your body's dangling like this movie
you're just hanging out and [ __ ] they're
just bumping into each other but uh nah
I'm blessed man you know what I'm saying
I'm just powered now I thought it was
nah I had just landed on a [ __ ]
for sure yeah
you playing basketball yeah for real too
you know people think it's a joke too I
bet he got crossover I'm like fam I do
this we got a baby ass rim in the back
it is on a serious level like stop but
yeah I'm happy I'm good so would you
land on the ball someone's ankle I
landed on a dude's leg Yeah like you
know like Harry man the homie didn't let
me land
it's all ex-nba players it's like it's
like at least so you're good at
basketball I played division one for one
you know oh yeah oh like division what
three three and two all right three and
two but still still not only playing for
one year you know it don't matter the
fact that you go hey you're on the
[ __ ] team that's that oh man I play
basketball that's tight no as a kid dude
I was really good at basketball I loved
that I played I played after school I
never played for school I [ __ ] got to
end one [ __ ] I'm hot so I'm like yo I am
hot sauce from Merced like on escalated
if I was taller I'm not doing all this
[ __ ] and then I was like yo I'm kind of
a ball hug
I tried out for sixth grade basketball
and I didn't make it and he told me
because you don't take a ball enough you
just pass too much you passed too much
stop yourself you stopped what you was
actually good at because I hope never
again hope you never again stop being
the real you for anything that [ __ ] hurt
I hope it was less than that there was
I'm never gonna let up again I'm never
passing these [ __ ]
did you make did you make seventh grade
or did you just give up no I just
started wrestling okay yeah no I play
basketball every day at my at my [ __ ]
apartment complex oh hell no
that [ __ ] serious street basketball gets
serious the elbows and the punches in
the face gets I went on the street I was
opening a real gym where it you know we
but it was crazy it's crazy because
there was a whole bunch of misconfusion
misconstrue things within the video
people was like is this teo's legs I tag
Tio into Terrell Owens now he took the
video he was the person who thought
about like I'm gonna take the video
playing basketball with to oh my God yo
come hoop all the time I forget man I
forget because you're a normal ass dude
I forget like you're on TV you guys
interview like the favorite you guys's
favorite people so I grew up my
grandma's Niner fan so I grew up Tio
that guy man and still in crazy [ __ ]
still look like a [ __ ] monster like a
beast you like that's GI Joe that's my
guy right there but yeah he was like and
I didn't even know he was filming me
y'all look back I said You [ __ ]
filming a video and he was like you're
gonna want to see this of your leg Yeah
and I was like I fam and then we had to
just wait on the ambulance to get there
I'm talking to them I don't know I'm on
the video everybody like how are you
just talking this I know you was on meds
I'm like I'm not on no man's Fam I'm
just trying to [ __ ] stay calm I'm
trying to breathe because my whole leg
is pointing West now
yeah oh so you were just actively trying
not to panic and freak out until you got
to the hospital basically for me it's
like what am I supposed to do like am I
supposed to scream in your face and like
does that make y'all feel good like what
does that like I don't get it when
people were like I don't know how you
not freaking out more I'm like but what
is that gonna do for anything I'm not
gonna get healed by freaking out it's
not gonna actually make me feel better
if anything me taking deep breaths also
my dad was a fireman you know not that
that [ __ ] matters not that means
anything but part of me thinks it does
like you could pass it down like yeah
that's not how it works sir but yeah
like I was just like breathe breathe
breathe and then I'll tell you this much
threw me in the back of the ambulance
[ __ ] didn't even secure my leg all the
way she was just bouncing around and
then [ __ ] him bro hidden [ __ ] no no
it wasn't even that fan was on his phone
he was like in his [ __ ] doing something
and I'm like such a person that like I'm
so chill brother like I'm saying to him
like I'm bothering him I'm like hey
excuse me I don't mean to bother you uh
you think you could like prop my leg up
a little more and put a little cushion
under it yeah hold on he was like oh
yeah you right yeah [ __ ] you think yeah
I'm right do that [ __ ] my fault could
you imagine you're paramedic that's
basically what he hit me with he was
probably taking selfies and [ __ ] like
yeah on live driving the ambulance like
yo I'm gonna get this clip on his show
of me like looking homie
it's like a whole portal you go through
[ __ ] man that's sad do you think that if
they would have caught the moment of you
[ __ ] yourself up would they put it on
ridiculousness no no no
there was nothing like it was no Richer
there was nothing funny nothing
ridiculous about it well it's just like
it'd be one thing if I got crossed up
because like he went that way his leg
went this way it'd be like kind of funny
it was like no I'm going up for a layup
I look down as a man under me I land
right on his leg my [ __ ] cracked it it
would only be on like scars remember
scarred back in the day it might make
scarred or remember the umroiding.com it
might be on rotten.com but it wouldn't
be on the addiction we still have
families around dude you threw a bag we
bring a bride and e-bomb's world people
like I don't I don't recall like that's
because you were soft as [ __ ] I'm trying
to watch some crazy [ __ ] I'm rotten at
two in the morning I was in grammar
school no that was before you know you
know when he went to school once the
school figured out they made it with
your [ __ ] everything was blocked you
couldn't go through nothing cause [ __ ]
are watching porn after school if you
let them [ __ ] if you left me after
school [ __ ] when the computers gonna get
used but uh uh for me it was like I knew
okay this was beforehand riding.com
right now coming you can go on there and
I don't know as a [ __ ] young boy I
don't know why your first idea is to go
to riding.com and see some kind of year
somebody's leg [ __ ] decapitated it
from the train that ran over there I
don't know why you think that I'm what
my friends did that you don't actually
and you never really want to look at it
it was like do this you went and you
went to it it was like ah but you go
through it and skim through trying to
look away not happy I hope to see a
titty or something
and no one else feels weird yeah yeah
what you just said is exactly what
happened I threw up off one over I can't
watch that [ __ ] I don't watch that my
homies did yeah no thank you well it's
not normal
the dude that's like volunteer the dude
who's like let's go to Rodney like that
dude is interesting to be honest the
fool that did that it does live outside
now yeah but now okay answer me this now
it's the topic at my house is it normal
for women particularly okay sounds like
it's gonna get sex let's go to watch
primarily morbid gruesome murder shows
just in there
it doesn't get sexy this is just real
soon sorry I'm sorry my apologies this
is just [ __ ] real why do girls do
this I don't know I think girls just
they did their fantasy is different they
their fantasy is just like you know I
could kill you right I just want you to
know that like they allow you to live
each day okay she poisoned them over
time oh I didn't realize that's what
okay he forgot their anniversary three
years in a row believe that yeah you'd
be more grateful if you just knew like
somebody could kill me and it's the
person I love
my fiance's mom stayed all week yeah she
was watching murder me
I'm watching
killed her in a bag I gotta get out of
here I'm gonna smoke Dabs in the back
see I'm not I'm not against the murder
mysteries it's when they start dvring it
it's when they start taping it they
taping murder mystery then you got a
real problems first of all they have
streaming Miss why are you still taping
things second of all yeah this is way
too much you're running out of murders
that means they're rewinding to know how
to kill you and where they made mistakes
I never took it there yeah you well then
you never do you just die that's how it
works you the person never gets the
chance to take it there he wakes up in
heaven yeah
yeah you might have saved my life yeah
thank you I mean just let her know I'm
appreciative just walk in the house for
no reason and now I'm just I said hey I
appreciate you for no [ __ ] reason
right you're gonna start watching less
and less episodes on your TV and be like
you know what I just need to appreciate
her more that's what's going on it's not
not true everything that's happening
she's Dr Drew me right now he did Dr
Drew's back it's cool in the [ __ ] out of
you today all right completely different
topic here we go
from Chicago I am all right you from
Chicago oh yeah because
Marty was telling me Marty's such a
Marty does such a good research I do my
research I'm like yeah I know this
person well and Marty's like by the way
here's an extended version of everything
you [ __ ] dummy but not the dick way
I'm just like
if we did a group project at Sewell he's
definitely the guy speaking okay all
right for sure for sure
support for today's episode comes from
True classic all right guys if you're
shaped like me you already know finding
a shirt is super hard you're either skin
tied around your stomach or you look
like a box also for everyone out there
that has abs and a six-packs of course
this shirt's gonna look way way awesome
on you but for everyone out there that
doesn't have a six-pack this is a more
flattering shirt first thing you're
gonna notice is the quality how soft it
is next thing you're gonna notice is how
it fits your shoulders your dad bot is
evaporating Away by way this true
classic T true classic shirts taper
around the bottom and they're tighter
around the chest it's gonna highlight
your attributes all right you want your
shoulders to look better but you don't
want your gut poking out this is the
shirt for you they got this dope Builder
on their website you can package all the
different essential things that they
offer together also true classic does
not just stop a t-shirt they have polos
workout shirts boxers Breeze same exact
taper guys all right as the same fit for
all the wide dudes and the big tall guys
out there they all go up to xXx okay on
most of the staple colors free shipping
included on all orders over a hundred
dollars a hundred percent 30 day money
back guarantee and if you want to go
ahead and take advantage of this right
now go to trueclassic.com and use the
code checkout dope d-o-p-e that's going
to get you 25 off come on guys it
doesn't get better than that you guys
already know me I own a clothing company
so me looking at the shirts they are
good shirts at a reasonable price true
classic tees your dad Bob thank you
guys it's all about confidence when it
comes to sex right I'm right a bunch of
things can set you off down to a bad
path of not having fun stress anxiety
lack of sleep diet bluetooth.com to the
rescue Bluetooth online service has the
same active ingredients as Viagra and
Cialis but in chewable form at a
fraction of the cost Bluetooth tablets
help men achieve harder stronger
erections in combat all forms of Ed and
because Bluetooth is an online
prescription service there's no awkward
conversations with a doctor there's no
weird office visits there's no bumping
into somebody you know at the pharmacy
getting your pills it goes direct to
your door and in the discreet box sign
up at bluetooth.com they're going to
link you up with one of their medical
providers evaluate your situation within
days you should be receiving your
prescription best part it's all done
online and Bluetooth will work with you
for your doses your prescription your
strength they are licensed medical
providers don't like swallowing pills no
problem Bluetooth tablets are chewable
Bluetooth is made here right in America
guys and there's no upsell to Pharmacy
because they're direct to Consumers
special offer for all the listeners
owners you get to try Bluetooth for free
use code dope at checkout pay five
dollars for shipping try it out for free
use our code dope at checkout and you
get a month your first month for free at
bluechew.com thank you guys so much for
being here back to the episode
uh I see pastors and you said your dad
was a firefighter my dad was a fireman
my mama was a pastor for the most part
and then my dad became a pastor randomly
later on in my life don't know why he
did that at the age I already did but
yeah uh that was double yeah we grew up
in the hood though it was interesting my
whole life was interesting uh
Chicago that you know what it is already
for west side of the upper like the real
Hood
but my parents you know they tried to
instilled us at an early age like just
because you from somewhere don't mean
you have to be of that you know what I'm
saying like so for me it was like we
hooped
we who played baseball excuse me
baseball
we did a whole bunch of different things
I actually went to I tell people all the
time my life was shaped it kind of just
like too extreme to the world I [ __ ]
with it it's a school called Whitney
Young in Chicago super academically
inclined school
um the Wachowski siblings went there
um Michelle Obama
yeah Matrix
um Michelle Obama went there shout out
to Vic Mensa he went there but it's like
it's a school that's like um
what [ __ ] nerds go
and kids would do really well all my
friends went to like brown and yell and
Harvard and [ __ ] like all my boys are
doing really well in life and [ __ ] but
for me it's like every day going back
home to the hood it's just like you live
completely in school I was a tough [ __ ]
I was [ __ ] like right roasting
[ __ ] slapping [ __ ] up if I
wanted to doing all the [ __ ] at home
by my crib it was like [ __ ] I'm a
regular [ __ ] over here I'm just trying
to fit in and survive this is cool
I'm chilling fam my parents are pastors
y'all got that [ __ ]
let's live in double lives my my uh
fiance her mom her both her grandparents
are pastors her mom everybody grew up so
I'm just showing her The Simpsons now
because she was not allowed to watch it
well I wasn't allowed to watch it either
but like who the [ __ ] gonna listen to
their parents my um but you know what I
will give my parents credit shout out to
them they wasn't those kind of pastors
no offense okay no offense to those
pastors I'm not saying that in a
disrespectful way but of course I'm
singing in more of a um with that strict
well no they were strict but like the
the thing they would teach us is that if
God gives us Choice who would they be
not to you know what I'm saying like God
gives us Choice God allows you to make a
decision from good of evil won't he so
why why would a parent tell oh it's your
job to do is lead me in the right
direction it's not your job to
necessarily make me do what you want me
to do you know what I'm saying even
though my parents would try but they
knew they boys was gonna do what the
[ __ ] he wanted to do it was three boys
and one girl we always
if anything so we just you know you're
not gonna be able to tell us every
single thing to do and we're gonna just
do it we got those kids or else I
wouldn't be where I am today you know
what I'm saying I was [ __ ] that was
going to roast the teacher and tell them
that they was a goofy ass and like I was
just that kid you know I'm saying I was
talkative but I was funny
I was my teachers they they hated me but
they laughed first okay you know they
never got too you're that kid suspended
all the time like I would you know I
would do all that [ __ ] and then my
school was like a a goody two-shoe
school so I could do what I deem not
that much and it'd be enough to get me
in like real trouble I got some [ __ ]
[ __ ] what kind of school is this but
yeah I didn't get in crazy crazy trouble
I want the [ __ ] that was out here like
I would never try to friend like on that
[ __ ] you know I was moving packs in the
early age little [ __ ] it's like now I
want the [ __ ] on that I was just on
[ __ ]
that was my thing I hooped and I was on
chicks yeah so
your music did you hear this man it's
not like my [ __ ] Grandpa Tom over
here you already know I call myself
Uncle Elroy you already know what it is
Uncle Elroy let's talk music real quick
though I grew up on Chicago air rap yeah
Kanye common consequence uh that whole
generation Lupe yeah now
did you were you loving that music
growing up of course I'm gonna just put
him over there real quick consequence
from Queens though but the rest of
[ __ ] is from Chicago for of for sure
for sure I love that rap god Kanye you
know what I'm saying was those are the
years I was in high school I thought I
was a little bit of yay I was just
telling my homie this I had wore this um
this maroon and fuchsia and red and a
little pink sweater for sweetest day
because I was like I'm about to go to
school and rack up all the [ __ ] they
gonna see my sweater and then my little
slacks and my little loafers would be
like how's this [ __ ] dressing like this
as a sophomore and that's just what
happened I pulled up all the chicks was
like yo he dressed so fly what the [ __ ]
he ahead of his time how he doing this
I'm like I know it's crazy I'm thinking
I'm on one I'm thinking I'm the flyest
kid ever I get off the bus because I'm
going back home I get off the bus
without here as soon as I got the bus
I said what it was because I'm back in
the hood
they was like no fam now but Carlton
yeah basically like what you got on fam
but uh nah I definitely grew up on yeah
I definitely grew up on Lupe for sure
Lupe is so underrated to me he's one of
my favorite rappers I grew up on combat
I grew up on twister big time I grew up
on uh Crucial Conflict do or die like
anything Chicago like I was really
listening to any Bump J anything in
Chicago because I you know I'm a Chicago
ass [ __ ] at the end of the day like I
love my city how you feel about drill
rap and all like Chief Keef the whole
generation I [ __ ] with it you know what
I'm saying about a lot of kids I mean I
[ __ ] with anybody else expressing
everything so I [ __ ] with all the kids
you know they living their life for real
they really out here for real so to me
it's always just an expression that's
what rap is it's about whatever you and
whatever group you believe you
connecting with whoever you connecting
with you know it's a whole bunch of kids
out here living in the [ __ ]
trenches for real so I'm connecting to
My Demo I'm connected to people so Chief
keep me here Innovative you know what
I'm saying like I love Chief Keef I
brought him more ridiculousness
he was against I I saw him at a
metaphor concert we started shopping by
the crib I was like yo bro and then he
his manager came and said he wasn't
going ridiculous because Chief ain't
gonna go he ain't gonna talk too much he
ain't gonna talk too much so he was just
like he wasn't going Ridiculousness I
was like I was like I got him say less
you know I'm gonna EP so I go I next day
I hit the whole team said I'm gonna
bring Chief Keef on we set it up Chief
Kee come on he say four words the whole
time Chief Keef hit come on and say no
[ __ ] I said why he asked me to come
over here if he gonna say four words but
I thought
since season two okay because people
probably don't I don't think I didn't
realize that people probably don't know
that oh yeah a lot of people executive
producer yeah
and that's just Thomas L Miller That's
the [ __ ] we used to see as kids remember
putting his people that's how Thomas is
like as soon as Thomas got successful
immediately started putting all his
people on positions in place to be
successful if they wanted to be so like
I heard Rob say like he's like I knew
when I did uh Ridiculousness like I
wanted that to be my uh America's
Funniest Videos I wanted to own it I
wanted it to go on forever yeah he'll
tell you he'll tell you how he um I
forget which magazine exactly it was it
could have been Hollywood Reporter or
one of those he was getting subscription
from it and uh and they came to his
house and it had just on the on the
cover and said America's home funniest
videos I forget the guy I'm going blank
because I've been smoking with y'all
shout out to y'all oh oh the Tom
Bergeron the actual guy you pulled that
name off into boner yeah yeah that yeah
that you pull that [ __ ] out there yeah
yeah that own and created uh American
funny videos he assigned another seven
year or five year deal worth like 600
million and Rob was just like yo for him
it was like boom you know he's always
been about his money number one and then
secondly he was like I could
legitimately modify this I could
modernize This and like we need a
refresher in this this field anyway so
he was like from there it was
I'm doing this for sure and he took it
to um to MTV he tells the story I
believe but he took it to MTV they had
actually Fantasy Factory wasn't even
picked up yet they had actually
um before Ridiculousness uh they had
actually
told him hey we do like this show but we
want you for like another show in the
style of Robin baby we want you for and
he was like oh well I'll only come back
if you allow me to set up my deal a
certain way so he got to start up his uh
his integration deal so he had all his
integration rights so every brand and
everything he had worked with within
that actual Fantasy Factory era those
were all deals he was doing on his own
whereas a lot of times networks own
those integration rights so like you
know if if MTV goes out tomorrow and
asked us to do a a spot for Taco Bell we
may get paid a percentage I mean a
little deal piece but we don't get an
actual any real skin in the game you
know what I'm saying so they they own
those rights he owned all the rights to
his own [ __ ] when he did Fantasy Factory
and then um they were like yeah come
back for a show making this long window
but I guess I'm here for this all right
like come back for a show and he was
like yeah as long as I can do this this
America's home funny video show too so
they picked up both shows the same day
he just had to shoot Fantasy Factory
first so it was a whole year and a half
that went by before he was able to even
jump into
um
ridiculous
damn I didn't realize I had no idea
everybody got these bags but you know
one of the dope as usual podcasts
appreciate it that's looking into the
next 30 Years like where do I want to be
through this that's what this all is
about no yeah you know what I'm saying
everybody if we sitting here and we do
anything well it doesn't have to
necessarily always be business either
it's just about life in general it's
about where the [ __ ] you want to go it's
about each day being a problem solving
waking up and being like all right what
are the problems in my life how can I
get closer to solving them uh so I think
that's always looking big picture and
looking at like where I want to go as an
ultimate goal where where's my Finish
Line what do I want to run through
versus you know piece by piece even
though it's day by day you know it's
still a marathon so it's like I you I
look at it at least and anything that I
do and I try to
be intentional and ask myself why am I
doing I don't want to do nothing in life
just to do it what [ __ ]
I could just do nothing then that's way
better than doing something
something well yeah that's easy way
easier I could just do nothing
to do this so for me it's like being
intentional and making sure that like
whatever we doing out here
I'm I'm looking through I'm being like
the dope as usual podcast where the [ __ ]
we going next you know what I'm saying
what is are we doing live shows are we
doing blah blah what are we doing like
that's what all this [ __ ] is about yeah
that's exactly I love the mentality man
this is what we this is that's that's
half our show is hey [ __ ] you
could do it too is it which is a
blueprints the [ __ ] is about yeah cause
y'all smoke weed yeah because [ __ ]
that smoke weed ain't got nothing else
to do but be positive
we smoked weed with the [ __ ] you never
see a [ __ ] just smoke I'm about to go
fight these [ __ ] true statement don't
happen uh yeah let's put out a bunch of
negative Vibes yeah energy intro stop
all that no there's too much we always
say there's too much weed money to be
made yeah did we fight yeah yeah it's a
motivational podcast but it's comedy
yeah there you go and then we talk about
[ __ ] our favorite shows yeah no for
no damn reason so real quick you said
you were a r you got into radio and
music all before you even did TV oh yeah
how you know I got into radio you told
me I didn't say I did right yo I could
have swore you did nah that's crazy I
don't think I said well I was in a note
okay yeah I used to work at Clear
Channel so I did work at Radio WGCI in
Chicago and kiss that family and all
that stuff I worked there but uh yeah I
used to walked in and asked for a job
yeah [ __ ] you that's been my mentality
all the time no I'm joking
you really got me yeah the Robin
Williams like I'll do your dinosaurs
that's not how I worked uh
well with Clear Channel I already
I've always just been aggressive about
the [ __ ] I [ __ ] want in life you know
what I'm saying so for me in college
during my only year in college when I
was not supposed to be hooping and focus
on academics I was really there working
on music and not myself but I was
working with um
songbook entertainment at the time who
had Trey Songz had a new artist named
Brandon Hines so I was helping promote
and kind of trying to break those dudes
at the time that's what I was doing for
my dorm room
um so I was just hustling hustling
hustling through Myspace through
different things on just getting their
records out more and trying to bring
recognition to both those orders I had
even I remember one point I pray all
these flyers and drove up to these
different I went to HBC you drove these
different hbcus and passed out flies on
campuses so it was these uptick in
Myspace plays and [ __ ] but just always
was hustling you know what I'm saying I
was listening uh I was reading the book
make it happen Kevin Lyles wrote that
book and he he went to Morgan State for
uh uh for for one semester and he was
the vice president he ended up becoming
like the president of Def Jam but he
also uh owns the the record brand uh
record label on 300. oh [ __ ] yeah so
yeah so Kevin is super successful but he
wrote a book called make it happen I
read that book as a freshman and I was
like yo he went to my same school for
[ __ ] only one semester I've been here
two already [ __ ] this and I'm about to
leave because this is what I want to do
I want to work in this field so um I had
left actually and and decided my one of
my best friends I did a movie when I was
12 years old one of my best friends uh
who was in the movie with me was like he
was moving out to LA as well because I
moved into La if you want to [ __ ]
like name drop [ __ ] it huh like name
like name drop what who are you talking
about
um Michael B Jordan you mean the guy
from Space Jam too that's what we know
him from
I like to do that like Europe
so wait is that why you is that and then
you said you moved out here yeah then we
moved out to LA at what age uh 1920. oh
okay for some reason I thought you just
said okay what the [ __ ] am I my freshman
year in college oh yeah college now you
skinned past the classic though okay
they're only rivaled by a Sandlot oh all
right Marty Marty's all about it Marty's
all about Mario's all about the facts
I'm like I don't even be uh talking
about that movie though is that is that
I'm talking about Hardball the movie
[ __ ] read Chicago watch uh
Happy Birthday Keanu Reeves today by the
way no no way yeah I love that fool I
don't believe that right yeah yeah damn
okay all right um so how you just walked
in was like yo I'm gonna get him I'm
gonna get a part in this role too in
this movie
not playing baseball I was ranked in the
state for baseball
and
um during the summertime My principal
they were having auditions at my school
I was at home though and my principal
called like isn't it like is it still
like really really really good at
baseball they're having these auditions
for baseball up here for this movie and
I went there and auditioned and got on
and then uh ended up getting on the main
team I'm gonna get on the main team in
the movie because uh
I was just always like a talkative funny
kid you know what I'm saying I was 12
years old and I thought it would be
funny I was in this because when you
were going through this process
upon on trying to make it an actual
movie like it was pretty intense we 11
12 years old but like the whole process
was you couldn't miss ground balls you
could have missed pop-ups if you missed
one you out fam you got it was a real
tryout like oh no it's like real real
like these are the best these the best
kids in the city like these in Chicago
is three million and a half people he's
the best kids in the city so it's like
you got to bring your [ __ ] let's go so
like yeah as kids we like doing this so
we had made it to the final day and they
were doing this little thing dudes
walking by and I'm a 12 year old living
the hood only go at this point I didn't
even went to the little uh uh academic
school yet I mean I'm at my regular
school you know I'm in the hood for real
like yeah my grandma's going [ __ ] so
only thing I know is I don't even I
hadn't even went to school with a white
person here so anything I know is making
a white person's voice in my head I say
I say to my little homies I better go
over to do this and make a white guy's
voice whatever the [ __ ] that means I'm
12. my homie's like I bet the [ __ ] you
won't so I'm thinking this is hilarious
as a kid I'm like oh this is hilarious
so I go over there dude I'm like hey
how's it going nice to meet you and the
guy's like uh oh how you doing kid nice
to meet you and you know guys like
what's your name I was like my name is
Sterling man I said what's yours he's
like Brian he's like pleasure meeting
you still like pleasure meeting you hey
you stay up sir and he leaves and he was
like okay cool whatever and
I'm thinking nothing of it I'm thinking
that's hilarious I'm 12 thinking this is
the funniest thing it's not even funny
as a kid I'm like this is hilarious oh
as a kid my friends are laughing
everything is hit did not know the guy
that I'm doing this whole [ __ ] who is
the director of the movie so the
director is just like I like this you're
killing him I'm trolling him and he's
like I like this kiss and his
personality which he also was one of the
creators and uh producers or or all that
so maybe he knew I was trolling him
maybe he was used to like kids being
funny as well but that's just me
thinking that but in the moment I'm
definitely trolling him and he bit on it
and he was like I want that kid on the
main team so he ended up putting me on
the main team on the [ __ ] cucumbers
in the movie but I don't [ __ ] talk
you know what I'm saying I'm not there
for that I'm just Jackson I play
baseball you know yeah that's [ __ ]
hardly you go back to school and yo
remember how good I am I'm in the
[ __ ] movie where you were a [ __ ]
movie star when he went back to school
all right the kids I mean you hit like
I'm from the hood I was a movie done let
me tell you like this I was a movie star
not only uh was I a movie star I was
moving stuff for some years in random
neighborhoods too it would be like a
rumor like that that kid played in that
movie yeah because it's like some of us
were really from Chicago I'm trying to
think of how many kids were really from
Chicago but I don't know how many of us
was really from the hood I think it just
was different for the kids from the hood
because it was just like yo we really
was in a [ __ ] movie I didn't say
nothing and I'm still like people like
yo that they called me Hollywood that
became my nickname for like three years
of my life I was Hollywood and I'd be
like yo that's that's not my name but
yeah but they'd be like yo Hollywood you
like it a little bit though
Hollywood [ __ ] again
Hollywood okay that's what he said and
[ __ ] that's what he meant earlier his
name was Hollywood and you play sports
you're on and I thought and I thought it
was funny but I got you I got you I got
you I'm gonna give you the one now go I
I was 4 11 as a freshman
yeah yeah yeah yeah I didn't hit five
foot until middle freshman year yeah oh
you hear these middle freshman I came
back each year it was just like a little
baby girl you're not short no I was five
three sophomore year then the junior I
was five seven everybody's like oh [ __ ]
five seven and then I was five ten and I
have my senior everybody's like you live
you're a grown ass man yeah but as a
freshman we and we had seven and eighth
graders in our school so as a freshman
[ __ ] I swear to God I was a
seventh grader I could not tell them
nothing I would have classes with them
they would swim it was good you're just
smart slow now come on yeah
this will speak in my life athletic
though like when you're up [ __ ] sucked
one of the best athletes in the school
though like that's different if you look
like short and [ __ ] baseball don't
matter you gotta hit nobody in the face
yeah [ __ ] block or Swamp People you
know playing basketball tonight I
honestly oh wait so you're back but
baseball I play second base shortstop
you know what I'm saying let's see the
star you're the star of baseball what
are you talking about besides the
picture
so it was a ball that was like coming at
me I might move that way so I could back
here and do so I can come back up the
back here to be a Showboat because my
dad played the miners for some years so
like yeah so baseball was like in our my
dad really my dad always joking say he
was Jamaican and he's not
um because he just had seven jobs with
like my dad was a pastor he really was a
actual Barber and hairstylist he worked
at soft Sheen which is a huge Hair
Company social uh he was a fireman uh um
he built he made us build homes with him
with just some other [ __ ] yeah this
is a different day too my dad was
building [ __ ] from not knowing how to
build [ __ ] when you had to open a Home
Depot book when you couldn't even go on
Google [ __ ] you could even YouTube it
and be like how to put down floors no
[ __ ] [ __ ] had to really read a book
and be like wait a minute my dad would
make us help him build [ __ ] with this
[ __ ] most frustrating what fam did you
have the TomTom guide then yeah to find
[ __ ] addresses yes my dad's truck
driver I'd be like I [ __ ] panicking
like what what street is it I was like
12 years old like Dad you [ __ ] do it
man see my dad would even bring him
address my dad would make us always
hustle a little bit he always felt like
you gonna have a job he he wouldn't do
this and swear to God it's a lesson and
everything which it is but he always
wants to put the lesson and everything
to you like you didn't need to put it
there I was gonna learn one way or
another but he would make us actually um
paint addresses on the actual on
sidewalks he'd be like yeah y'all can
start a little business go around here
and knocking on doors or either we
either we out here shoveling snow for
everybody because other than Chicago or
we paying addresses because he would say
as a fireman's hard to find an address
sometimes it's true when you pull up so
he would make us paint the actress
Pizza Guy pizza guy [ __ ] [ __ ] please
yeah brand new yeah it is real yeah so I
mean the hustles you know what I'm
saying but your Hardball was just a
little it was a look it was a bigger
part of my life a whole bunch of [ __ ] I
was talking to a friend about this not
too long ago like there was like some
real [ __ ] that it'll give you guys some
insight about the people wouldn't even
know there's some stuff I wouldn't even
talk about because I don't [ __ ] care
about this [ __ ]
when we filmed the movie hard about we
were all kids like I said we came out to
Los Angeles for the first time for the
premiere and the premiere was September
10 2001
one day before September 11th
so we legitimately are having the time
of our lives as kids as we watch this
Premiere and blah blah blah blah and we
wake up in the morning and boom news is
crazy obviously you know what I'm saying
super intense from there obviously shut
down all planes so us as kids had to we
had to then have Paramount get us a big
basically coached a huge but there are
because people didn't want to fly even
if you weren't stuck if you could find a
flight nobody wanted to fly yeah so it
was like okay we're gonna give you just
coach bugs so it's also this experience
that we had as kids that we all rode
this [ __ ] bus back from Los Angeles
to Chicago terrorism because okay
because of terrorism terrorism brought
us together
it's okay it's after 20 years now you're
allowed to are you allowed to laugh a
little horrible [ __ ] sorry guys
it wasn't so normal to have horrible
[ __ ] happen when that happened no it was
way more jarring when that happened man
you remember when life used everything
used to be more like more jarring when
[ __ ] I was talking with my friends about
this [ __ ] he was talking about rap like
not to make it too dark but it's my rap
He was like
remember when Tupac and Biggie died it
was just them and it was the biggest
thing in the world for so many years
that these two rappers had died and it
was like what the [ __ ] these rappers
died
now rappers just dropped like floss it
was world star posts it's literally it's
the craziest [ __ ] in the world in the
feed
and that's it that's that's sad you're
making me sad oh bro that hurts man
because now you think about it's like yo
everybody just have fun be happy make
some music about like [ __ ] painting
signs and [ __ ] that's gonna be
motivational man high five each other
because shit's sad people died so fast
and it's like yo I don't even know who
that rapper was yeah and then you'd see
like Whoa We had a huge follow this fool
was crushing it that's yeah that's fun
think about people who pass away and
then something big happens right after
it and they don't get no Shine for their
death you ever think about them being in
like heaven you how you think they feel
they be looking down that's some
[ __ ] why would Donald Trump say that
a day after I die this is some [ __ ]
nobody remembers me now
I only have I was only out there for
about a day a day and a half
dude that's sad as [ __ ] expect because I
always say the the 911 thing he's like I
was at a Premiere I always think like
what were you doing like ah my mom was
going to join the army that day and I
thought she was really good murdered at
the Capitol she was one of the capital
of California she was going to take her
test for the Army and I'm sitting there
at home with no cell phones back then
like losing my [ __ ] mind for six
hours until she showed up I just
coincidentally and I was going to sign
up for the Army and I stayed home that
day I'm like I'm sexy at home I'm
[ __ ] staying home and I stayed home
and I'm watching [ __ ] MTV
uh that's that band Fuel the with the
blonde hair the guy that was on and I
remember and that was it that was it
then then terrorism yeah that's pretty
much what happened you're from out here
I'm from like uh the the middle uh my
Fresno Mercer area yeah like the shitty
same [ __ ] part no I'm from Buffalo
Buffalo you did say that yeah yeah damn
this took a crazy ass turn sorry Chicago
we're talking about music but that's
where you met Michael B Jordan on
Hardball
you guys moved out here at 19. yeah
that's how you got into radio and music
that's how we [ __ ] got it yeah I know
I know it was 30 minutes ago no no we uh
I moved out here and I was working in uh
a r out here a little bit and I had
already interned at the radio station in
Chicago
uh so for me interning when I actually
came out here first I didn't have a real
[ __ ] plan so I had to move back home
because I didn't have no [ __ ] money
right there you have to take miles back
home so we're back home for like six
months and I worked that clip I worked
that Clear Channel for those six months
and people in collection will tell me
all the time that the whole time I walk
around the office just saying I ain't
gonna be here for long as I promise
y'all but I don't even remember saying
that but I know it was also my
personality then I was just not polished
I was a crazy kid about or not polished
at all now you're like I keep that [ __ ]
yeah yeah but I'm just like I'm gonna
get out of here soon and and lo and
behold six months went by a year and I
and I did move back out to LA and things
worked themselves out the second time I
had more of a plan for sure and uh yeah
you know all of this [ __ ] all this [ __ ]
yeah I was I was 19 20. I just said 20.
yeah yeah
so you've been out here damn near half
your life
no question yeah no so you're into
boxing I am into boxing big time what's
up though yay what we don't know a lot
about boxers
all right Michael B Jordan he can
actually box though right
yeah because I heard I read in our
article that yeah it means that you're
my friend I could still fight him though
I mean like you're like I'm saying yeah
like in the sense of like if you're
training now he's going on Creed Three
this is his third time but if you're
trading for all these movies all this
time like even if you're pretend boxing
right you're still doing certain actual
real things to a certain level that
you're gonna be you're gonna still be
able to test any any random [ __ ] out
here yeah for sure so I'm not gonna say
oh yeah he could be Javonte Davis like
no so who wants to fight the full from
Black Panther nobody I'm like I [ __ ]
fight a superhero
what about one of the Paul Brothers
though
he'd [ __ ] it's like are you a promoter
no I'm just gonna say that's a question
I mean I don't know do I think one of
the Paul brothers would win
or did I think they're challenging
everybody in the world I'm gonna go
ahead and say Mike gonna win but I don't
think Mike gonna take that fight I think
I think I think that's the people who
need that money you know what I'm saying
yeah okay well I mean [ __ ] reminds the
movies
yeah that's a good point
why risk it yeah like because if you go
in that fight and you lose by anyway
like anything happens where you lose
like why was I even here yeah what did I
do this to myself
again like we said earlier why naive
this morning and just smoke a joint yes
why did I do this as you looking up like
damn nothing I lost damn what the hell
happened right now how do you feel about
the like all the celebrity boxing
matches like do you kind of just like
like turn your nose up to it being
somebody that's into real boxing man I
think all this [ __ ] is cool I think I
think anything in life like I'm a dude
that likes to
ruffle feathers but not in an aggressive
way but in more of a way like who is the
ruler of anything you know what I'm
saying who is to say somebody can't do
something if you can find a way to
Market it if you can find a way to bring
people to it if you can find a way to
monetize it in whatever way that who the
[ __ ] is the person to tell you can't do
it I put out music not only because I
think I'm pretty decent that and I'm
getting better at it I do enjoy doing it
for sure I put it out just because I'm
like who is anyone else to tell me that
I can't like like this is something I
want to do like I can do this I can for
sure do this so when I look at The Ball
Brothers like even if I don't like
whatever the [ __ ] they stand for even if
I like whatever it is I'm cool I'm cool
with Logan I'm I don't have a problem
with those guys at all I can still be
real about like I [ __ ] with a hustle I
love watching the [ __ ] hustle
yeah I love watching people invent
things and make things like we didn't
know we even used the Paul Brothers in
certain ways right they made us they
made them laying for themselves they
made just realizing I have nothing
against that to me that's dope like I
didn't even know I needed to see Logan
in WWE and I've seen him and I'm like yo
you belong there the [ __ ] looks
like he belonged as a wrestler for sure
and I'm like yo but also like just see
him I don't even watch WWE I've seen
some clips I'm like yo fam I don't mean
to be the I ain't no dick rider you look
like you were born to do this like you
look like you belong
so like for me I just look at those
dudes do I think that they're better
than do I think those zoos could fight
real boxers no do I think that Jake Paul
could fight like a real boxer when I say
real box I mean like Champions I mean
like people that are contenders no I
think that he is a decent fighter though
and I think he's getting better each day
and he's been doing it long enough now
that people within the real fight space
to tell you bro has he's doing some
[ __ ] up he's beat some people love
people in the gym who who are real
Fighters but I don't think like when we
talking about
the guys I don't think I don't think
yeah by any means when he even mentions
Canelo name that he really wants that I
think Canelo would break him in half and
I wouldn't even want that for Jake Paul
I gotta be like why you do this to
yourself you you were making money with
your teeth and now you're he was making
money and doing his own thing and then
you start bringing in these real people
my only guess is that you're hoping that
you can get one huge payday and just get
the [ __ ] out because you're not going
like but you only take that fight when
you ready to be done because I promise
you my friend you will be done after
fighting a real Champion yeah yeah
that's a different story but like you
said we didn't even know we needed them
yeah it's entertainment it is truly it's
just entertainment like oh this YouTuber
I watch
look out it was kind of funny cool it
was kind of cool because I'm on YouTube
watching fights as it is I might as well
watch the fools we were watching anyway
fight it's like Celebrity Death Match
remember on MTV a little claymation dude
yeah
yo if they brought that bag and you guys
remember Def Jam fight for New York or
Def Jam Vendetta could you imagine a
modern day version of that video game
right now with updated we're gonna be
the best fighter ah the whole one is
David Banner so you guys got to tell me
who's gonna be the best one now who
gonna be the best fighter when you look
at all the um
the rappers who you like yo this
person's gonna be the best fighter on
the video game I Wanna Know
DMX gets grandfather into the game right
like but who but I mean I mean active
rappers right now yo I know Waka Flocka
Flame is pretty [ __ ] big yeah but you
naming people that was on the last one I
mean like ain't no look is he on the
last one I think Waka Flocka might have
made it now he ain't making it to he
probably made it to the one when it was
like on PS3 or something on the way out
but I'm saying like in my head it's like
it's Lil Uzi like Rey Mysterio yes he is
he's gonna do this that's what I'm
saying yeah
that was a great comparison because he
is the rapist that's what I'm saying
like the rapper Jaleel I don't even know
much about him but like he crazy as [ __ ]
he big as [ __ ] I just feel like he have
David Bannon swag big boom boom Swag
yeah it's a whole that'd be interesting
though then she bring that back that'd
be cool yeah I still don't know I still
don't know who's the best fighter I
gotta be honest who do you think I I
don't know the best I'm trying to figure
out who's gonna be the best fighter out
of rappers right now damn yo my father I
don't know my my whole rap actually
exists in the 90s that's true that's
true that's true if it's not twisted if
it's not yeah Roy Jones Jr boxer used to
rap oh yeah maybe he gonna be the best
y'all must have forgot forgot we tried
to Roy we tried to predict
but here you are reminding us
I'm gonna pass bro I can't think I can't
I'm really thinking about I'm stumped
too so like it was a question that
sounded good in theory but if none of us
have answers it's a bad question great
question
uh I just don't want to be wrong oh yeah
he might get his ass whooped too
we got you want to shift in the uh who
are you in the night we gotta do real
quick
hey we do something here called who were
you in the 90s and I asked Mario like is
he at least like around our age like yes
perfect this is gonna work all right so
we do something called who are you in
the 90s yeah and basically we tell you
two we ask you two things yeah you pick
in between them Marty did who are you in
the 90s Chicago version for you today
okay first time you've ever switched it
up so I really [ __ ] I'm excited for
this one Marty you take it away start
this off
all right so normally like a normal who
are you in the 90s question to be like
Adam Sandler or Jim Carrey okay and then
you have to think about in the 90s as a
kid you know what I mean like what were
you doing was that was it who I actually
was or who was a more of a fan or most
not all these are going to be people so
it's like imagine yourself little kid in
the 90s like would I rather would I
rather I guess you would do who you
rather yeah
let's go let's go okay I'm [ __ ] with
it Michael Jordan or Bo Jackson
oh Michael Jordan okay easy you're a
baseball star though I thought yeah yeah
but Bo Jackson wasn't even like I mean
he was a Royals player more than
anything oh it was okay well I mean I
thought he was in Chicago this whole
career you know no boy Jackson in
Chicago the Sox for a few but also I was
in the Sox fan I was a Cubs fan uh okay
yeah
yeah Chicago's is it [ __ ] that bit
I'm going for the first time this this
month it's pretty busy it's the third
biggest city and I have no I have never
been anywhere but I went to New York but
you know what I'm not offended my girl's
from Montana which is not even a real
place but uh and she and she would clown
me all the time because I would talk
about Chicago like you talk about it
like it's so big I'm like it's the third
biggest city in the country I don't I
don't believe you I don't think most
people realize that I don't think 10th
because I've only been the ones before
are you ready La yeah
I actually went into Houston Dallas
Austin because I know Texas is like I've
never been there so I have no idea I
have no clue right okay Seattle's pretty
big I lived in Portland Portland is
pretty [ __ ] vast okay what are we at
like seven it's up there Portland you
think Seattle is pretty big Seattle's
even have a basketball too I don't know
I'm just talking about land mass man
I've never been to Chicago I've never
been I went to New York for the first
time a couple weeks ago oh really I've
never been anywhere and I lived in
Portland oh man you gotta bounce around
so we're doing it now like I'm trying
I'm trying [ __ ] yeah I'm trying now that
I'm beat a nation doing stuff you know
yeah actually go but Chicago's number
three yeah man number three it's a great
place great great place if you go in the
summertime you may not ever want to
leave I'm being serious
dead ass people go there all the time
and be like summertime shot
Kanye West
it's a great place Kanye West
animals all right Ferris Bueller Home
Alone
I'm gonna go home alone okay I'm gonna
go home alone just because that's more
in my pocket Ferris Bueller was right
before me but I [ __ ] with Ferris
Bueller this dope and it's Cubs in there
it's called references it's Ferris
Bueller but Home Alone yeah but Home
Alone that [ __ ] is hard right there yo
this is the best movie it's the best
question you've ever came up with and I
went
they're both they're from they're you're
right they're both Chicago you're right
you would have thought two of my
favorite I never even put it together
are these movies being Chicago movies
why would they be why because it's the
third largest city in the country that's
why there's so many I think a family
matters I think I associate with Chicago
with Family Matters oh cool I just see
the water
and then I'm about to be hyped that's
all I know like oh here we go what's he
gonna do today
all right let's continue all right no
okay moving on baseball okay you can't
be biased on this one though Rookie of
the Year Hardball power
uh I'm gonna go hard bro okay what do
you mean I can't be buying if I could
buy home dudes horrible
pretty easy call for me yeah slide that
pass here look at this
it's a great view that's good I'm being
biased okay hey man we all we as long as
you're honest you know but I gotta be
honest I really did think like yo if I
broke my [ __ ] arm
I could be strong like that yeah when I
was a kid I was done
yeah every kid like when we go for balls
like
no big deal breaks it breaks you know
until I really [ __ ] my arm up on the
monkey bars and I'm not having it no
more yeah I'm sorry I can't continue
all right Barbershop one or two
oh
I I I'm I'm gonna say Barbershop too
just because I
think I had that DVD and I watched it a
whole bunch so I just think I'm much
more familiar with it but I [ __ ] with
both of them I [ __ ] with the whole setup
I [ __ ] Cube I [ __ ] DeRay Davis the
Chicago Legend he was in the movie as
well a whole bunch of people in the
movie but it's a great movie it's a
great great film classic yeah
keep going but all right here we go
all right
this this might I don't know if this is
going to be done in your wheelhouse or
not Dick Butkus or Mike Ditka
my dick
uh real quick wild names we're like very
like
we didn't need two dicks anymore back to
back yeah and it is a buck because
you're right it's Mike yeah Mike is the
only like and that could even be yeah
dick buckets but like I don't like going
dick Focus uh I feel the cornered right
now I feel attacked
uh next question okay all right last one
Chicago style pizza or hot dogs
hot dogs oh this is hot good pausing the
Glizzy but yeah I'm gonna go with uh hot
dogs no I mean I don't like deep dish I
think deep dish is a very touristy thing
it's for tourists if you like [ __ ]
lasagna yeah it's lasagna yeah it's good
yeah it is good but it's just like a
heavy ass if you just try to get the
itis and [ __ ] go [ __ ] yourself yeah
it's the right car yeah
but if you want to just like we had to
get some quick in there it's fresh uh
Chicago style hot dog is it we had a
Chicago native on here recently and I
was like deep dish I don't know and he
called it Blasphemous yeah he was very
like what are you fun saying right now
he's talking about our pizza I so I
assumed he's from like Chicago Chicago
because we got this thing in Chicago
he's from like right here okay yeah he
might yeah he's they defend stuff we
don't know about
because I'm saying like when you from
the crib like that's the first thing you
meet somebody they're like oh you might
hear somebody in a different room oh
from Chicago Chicago [ __ ] he gonna make
sure he walk over there and see what
part of Chicago are you from instantly
that person could tell you're really
from Chicago and that person normally be
like oh well I'm not I mean I'm not
really from Chicago Chicago I'm from um
oh it's the area over oh you know where
such and such is you like [ __ ] that's
an hour away that's 45 minutes away and
like you can somewhat maybe out here in
the way La is set up say like I'm coming
from my Lane be 45 minutes away I get it
but not in Chicago like you are in a
different area fail for sure for sure
kind of excited bro he's talking about
it like it's [ __ ] great April said it
was the greatest said it was the nicest
best downtown she was like no no you
don't understand like you really need to
go when we drove we were moving out here
we had all of our [ __ ] in U-Haul she's
like we should take a detour to hit
Chicago just to see it I'm like Chicago
yeah but she every time it comes up
she's like downtown is great it is
amazing we're slipping we're learning a
lot today yeah man we're learning a lot
all right I think that was it for the
Huey in the 90s yeah maybe we just had
maybe a couple of quick fan questions
all right yes I'm pretty damn High yeah
let me just say that right we'll do it I
got pretty awesome big ass stupid joints
get them things like fingers I was like
that's crazy I'm gonna be smoking like a
elegant lady nah nah that's how I'm here
[Laughter]
you know every time I every time I smoke
a joint like that I always think like
this is how an old woman would smoke
yeah and I feel I feel like a good
person yeah
responsible I have one of those long
Cruella Deville things oh yeah the long
no no I have one from this antique shop
it's like a long pipe thing but you put
the joint in words how often do you use
it [ __ ] seldom okay very very rare okay
but I need to bust it out more if you
see this I have a roach clip like this
long but the right guess the right yes
you got
the right movie just be watching Step
Brothers
my bad ready
go for it today Marty oh okay go for it
all right we got Skater Pro zero 420
what was one of your happiest moments
with big black R.I.P
one of my happiest moments with big
black oh
[Music]
that [ __ ] gonna sound like lame but
it'll sound like you're just rappers my
guy like yeah black is my guy so like me
and black would eat that have worked
together but not how I worked together
he might just pull up on me and kick it
but like a real [ __ ] he was also from
Chicago low-key no [ __ ] yeah yeah
now he lived himself he lived in the
South but he was from Chicago hey when I
first met him he he was he was geeked to
tell me he was from Chicago and I was
caught on guard because number one I'm
like this big black that's dope and then
secondly I'm like you're not from
Chicago bro
Chicago
I was like you're not from Chicago he's
like no I really am he was I moved to
Mississippi I think it was like
when he was in his teens or something
like that but he showed me pictures of
him back in Chicago he was a big beers
fan whole bunch of [ __ ] but that was my
guy big sneak ahead well always had a
new heat but funny ass dude man like a
funny ass dude good ass dude I'd be
missing black sometimes my God yeah
R.I.P black for sure
all right we got Stacks all spelled with
x's and s's oh [ __ ] what was it like
living with Michael B Jordan oh no it
was cool no hold on hold on the way you
say it early he's like I got [ __ ] now
you're with Michael B Jordan kids
smiling around or you guys are just
murdering the town I gotta know nah just
slight smile and that joint tells me
everything I need to know it's okay
how much of a movie star was he when you
guys moved he's already in the wire okay
yeah that's a good point no no no he's
he was over 19. no yeah you but you guys
no no no that's true but you guys are
thinking about
you knowing him now and knowing that he
was in The Wire
but when you're in those moments people
aren't just the wire wasn't even that
big until afterwards
the wire end up being a bigger TV show
oh for sure now he's saying that he's
like a superstar no no no no no no I'm
just saying because he was saying like
how big like I think we both was just
people who wasn't I mean I wasn't even
in the industry but I don't think he was
known yet like when we moved out here
Mike wasn't known like at all oh I
really totally only meaning like
you talkative he's he's talking he's
going out now we both party promoters
I'm saying when we first moved here like
we really was hustling like it was like
we you guys are on your other [ __ ] okay
I'm just saying like
you don't get paid for real until later
on in your careers a lot of times and as
you know in these different Industries
you could be somebody else on a TV show
on a movie or you might not have your
big break necessarily in those first
Seasons or yeah in that first movie so
you could be on the wire and still not
have money you know I'm saying you could
be on a TV show and be like Oh I'm just
I'm hoping to renegotiate if we make it
to season two or three a whole bunch of
people so he did a season of The Wire so
he was still like trying to hustle and
make it in the industry you know what
I'm saying but like obviously you grind
you grind you grind you grind you grind
um but not it was it was it was dope
that's like that's my real best friend
like it was it was dope because you know
always just encourage each other in
different whatever goals it is in life
that we want to do always just been
super encouraging each other to be like
and then you can do this you know I
worked with Mike you know in a in a
capacity in a lot
so just to see him constantly grinding
was always great was there a moment
where it's like oh [ __ ]
it's different now was there yeah
Fruitvale Station Fruitville Station was
the movie that that blew up everything
for him like it was between that movie
and another movie at a time and he
picked that movie to uh ended up
shooting which was an indie film which
was Ryan coogler's first film actually
um uh and it performed
you know first of all Mike performed
[ __ ] incredible but it performed
really well at all of the film festivals
and uh
it's our first time just being you know
as we at the crib you know just seeing
that everyone's taking notice you know
he's getting congratulations from people
that we didn't even know [ __ ] just
being rude no he existed yesterday you
know what I'm saying he might get a
tweet from Oprah you like what the [ __ ]
so like that was incredible to see that
like yo I this feels real you know what
I'm saying and I think he's done a great
job at just you know
um staying at it you know what I'm
saying because it could be real all you
want you could be in the moment all you
want you know what I'm saying it's about
standing out into being consistent I
think he's in a great job being
assistant yeah I mean you look at his
IMDb it's like doesn't stop yeah
all right one more we got let's see here
uh who is your biggest inspiration
growing up her biggest influences would
you say was there somebody that you
really looked up to I mean cliche again
prank my dad for sure like
you know for me my dad just did
everything he made me think that
anything was possible but he he would
make me feel like he could do it so I'll
be lying man you know what I'm saying
I'm spotting this dude uh I could
definitely do this if I put my mind to
it like he always just gave you you know
in every room he he always affected
people as well for me it was just like
oh seeing this dude he didn't even
[ __ ] do anything [ __ ] that's just
being [ __ ] real but like when I think
about like athletes and stuff like I was
one of those dudes that like I I've
never like idolized like any any
personal television like I never had
like a a crush a celebrity crush going
up I I was the crazy dude in school
thought I could pull that girl yeah a
crush are y'all [ __ ] crazy crush me I
can't pull I just gotta meet her yeah I
was that crazy kid now I was a crazy kid
for sure yeah that kid
like oh he's crazy
older than him
I mean that's the mentality really that
you want to have in life oh of course
but you had that young oh sometimes
don't get that right until we're like
no no I was legitimately the
nine-year-old who thought that my
parents I thought I had a I thought I
had six years old if I had a girlfriend
she was 22 years old that's not even a
joke I used to say all the time when I
was my girl I was seven actually seven I
went to like we went to like some little
weird event where I got interviewed at
it and it was like people being funny
and say hey what's your name little man
I couldn't even [ __ ] talk yet I had a
lisp and I used to be like
hey what's your name
foreign
You Got a Girlfriend yes
you got a girlfriend I said yes I get
frustrated too but my [ __ ] didn't
understand me like it was like it was
their fault I said yeah so he was like
oh okay uh oh he said yes what's your
girlfriend's name her name Deborah she's
22 years old
her name Dara she's 22 years your
girlfriend is 22 years old yeah he
thinks Mama yeah he thinks his
girlfriend is 22 years old um I was just
that kid that thought like oh
y'all just you know what I'm saying you
ain't you take that swag on come here
your confidence needed to go up through
the roof delusion is what they call it
yeah delusional but I love it because
most kids don't [ __ ] have that if
they do they lose it about 10 when the
older kid [ __ ] punks them it's like
it's over because that happens I've seen
it happen in person yeah to know that
you have that and still have that it's
very unique man it got me through rooms
and my head is what got me through rooms
and people be like I don't even know if
what he said back there was right yeah
his confidence yeah made me believe I
would tell people all the time VIP is 90
mental if you walk up to the
[ __ ] rope and say move this hey
fam hey come on second one come on don't
even look at the bouncer just don't
leave it alone hey get your ass up
so that's full of fam I know John told
you you ain't gotta be a [ __ ] job
everybody knows a Giants said John is a
part owner for sure you like John should
text you on my bathroom what's your name
Steelo okay yeah I got you I got you I
got you uh if anybody else come up here
and they say my name is up to me tonight
cool you just walk in it's like oh man I
guess he was one of them dudes I don't
know nobody here Phil
90 mental that [ __ ] was [ __ ]
hilarious yeah there again that's a
shirt VIP is 90 mental
yo thank you for that that's a that's
literally a [ __ ] bumper sticker
yo so um no I don't we didn't I've never
had that as a kid and I'm so glad to
hear it I've seen a few kids like that
and even as an adult I remember told you
my homie's wedding this kid was dancing
as [ __ ] this kid was James Brown this
little seven-year-old boy had the entire
wedding
dancing like yo this kid's going places
yeah you should always see that kid you
know it and you know and you follow him
like yeah that gets [ __ ] hard and
that's what they probably said about you
like this Fool's crazy he's got a 22
year old girlfriend we'll see him on TV
soon did those kids actually go places
like do you think those kids and you're
like that kid actually went Place well I
just saw him this year did you I'll see
him on still killing it I think so man I
have a video of him this [ __ ] fool
jumped on top of a car and just started
breakdance on top of a car and I I just
how does he know
seven eight or he's still oh this was
this year's this year oh so you've been
watching them just for a couple minutes
I said I saw this kid went wow oh that's
the first time I've seen the key like
you make you have the most confidence
I've ever seen in anybody I've ever met
at your second seven yeah I love that
[ __ ] it's amazing and he's got kids he's
got kids so I'm looking that I've lived
through all I just got Snapchat to look
at my homies kids I'm like yo what is
this little doing today first day of
school [ __ ] yeah and I'll just smoke
weed on my steps
but you know it's gonna keep kissing
that confidence when they got it young
keep them with that confidence for sure
there's still it more in them like my
girl my girl's son he's five
he thinks he is the coolest [ __ ] kid
in the world because I make him believe
he is the coolest character he knows me
how could he not be the greatest that's
all you had to do kid so I like I'm
[ __ ] instilling him all day like Yo
dude cause he'll watch stuff on on TV or
YouTube and be like that kid's cool I'm
like thank you
I ain't trying to hate on that kid or
nothing but you way cool thank you yeah
yeah like you
you fam what yeah that kid can't even
compete with you fam and he starts when
we're not there like even in the house
he may still act like you know I'm still
trying to see if I'm cool around Steelo
when I'm not around if he's at school
we're here he thinks he is the coolest
guy to ever exist somebody I love him I
[ __ ] love it it's perfect yeah that's
what you're supposed to go anywhere it's
90 mental it's 90 cool it's 90 minutes
getting good with your teachers right
there has there been any gas on
ridiculousness that stand out like this
person's energy was just different when
he came through or she came through like
different like what good like big energy
like undeniable like just different like
like funny like all these people like
yeah I mean it just stood out like
killing me I'm sorry guys
um damn uh like stood out it's funny
it's been a whole bunch of guests that
I've said in the past like little John
was great Mac Miller was amazing
um
I'm trying to think of who's just been
like oh Eric Andre's been crazy he's
been funny yeah I'm trying to think of
who else has been on the show that I'm
oh Rick Ross was really funny Rick Ross
is funny I don't know if you want to
talk about how funny Rick Ross is Rick
Ross be on social media being really
[ __ ] funny but Rick Ross was really
funny how ridiculous as well it's been
some funny guests I don't know I don't
know I've enjoyed I mean as you can
imagine if we've had 1100 episodes we've
probably had at least 500 guests uh I've
enjoyed most of the guests I haven't
really had any guests that I was like
there was one dude that came home said
some racist [ __ ] what the [ __ ] yeah
after TV yeah he thought it was funny
and they was looking at me like please
don't kill this dude and I was like nah
we I'd like give him a signal I'm an EP
I'm still trying to make sure my this is
my business as well so I make sure you
know like we good like like I ain't
gonna slap on me up like we going are we
chilling but they like they stopped it
after it was absolutely not okay we'll
we'll delete the academy we'll delete
that I was like look y'all deleted y'all
want to but also
it might be better if you want to let
him be racist on TV because the people
at least see that you're racist yeah
versus it wasn't directed at me or else
I I wouldn't even it wouldn't have been
like no he could always be his ass it
was it was something about black people
on a video
and uh tried to try to pull me in I
think because he felt the room the
energy of the full room because we we
were filming with live studio audience
during that time too so the whole room
boom so he felt it and tried to like
bring me in and I was like absolutely
not [ __ ]
I can let you say it somewhat and I'll
slap you up what you're not gonna do is
make me on your side like hell no I'm
gonna let you die in this song
has nothing to do with me
do you got do people send you crazy ass
[ __ ] all the time it will not be opened
no no I think early on people thought
that was like people really believe to
themselves like hey I think if I send
this video to Steelo it'll make it on
the show and there's never once it has
happened never once I've ever seen the
video no I mean I'm gonna say
technically if I saw some video I don't
even submit if I just saw it I guess
that we we have to Source videos we do
but we uh we still pay for them we
licenses them so whatever resource
videos I just think people have gotten
to a point where you're like no this is
not gonna actually make it on the show
and they've said on each season please
do not submit videos that's what I said
in the very beginning but early on yeah
I would see like crazy videos of people
sending me like private messages and me
like this is insane and do you not look
at the internet just a way to work
do not look at the internet and watch
[ __ ] be like oh man I just saw this this
morning now I gotta do it at work I feel
like it's not as genuine oh no no no no
no no no because it's like it's still
it's still like if I saw it at home I
may have said something in my head but
also like that's not the same as saying
it at work in front of people working
off people so if I say something that
work Rob May respond then I may respond
let me respond again so it's like it's
way different than me just being in my
head watching the video but I don't know
what videos we're watching you know I'm
saying I don't I don't ever know until I
get there I watch it live right there
I'm just oh okay okay I control the
videos
number one question
I'm just [ __ ] around or is he
breathing I know I can people have
thought this as people you know what's
funny is that we've had guests if people
want to really go if we got real fibs
people that go back and really check
we've had guests
freaked the [ __ ] out couple to show a
freak out that I'm really controlling
like I thought you was controlling but I
know he was really controlling it that's
crazy but controlling me I've been
control Rob jokes about it like we
didn't even asked him if he knew how to
control it we just told him he had the
job and then day one we had him control
um but yeah and I'm definitely
controlling the videos I mean it's it's
it's it's better that way too because I
get to work back back back back and work
and point out things and everything else
in between to be like let's make sure we
get some good [ __ ] here on each video
we'll probably stop you may hear one
joke on each video or maybe a half a
joke sometimes uh we may stop each video
and break down each video in those
because what we're filming with I think
are like five Clips per package so we'll
break down those videos a whole bunch
like we may spend
may not seem like any time I had to be a
five second clip but we'll spend
a minute on it you know what I'm saying
just talking [ __ ] about it making it
funny so uh I mean a lot goes into it
and then editability [ __ ] cam but
yeah I really respect that you guys did
the full weed episode and switch the set
like oh yeah yeah that's funny yeah I
was surprised too I was shocked when I
got to work I was like are we doing this
that's what we doing today this is crazy
yeah that was cool that was cool I mean
what was the push behind that was that
MTV or was that like you guys trying to
like no that was on TV actually uh it
was like some thematic [ __ ] like
sometimes [ __ ] um we we had it was us on
our side because MTV doesn't
necessarily produces shall we produce
the show and you know they pay for it
yeah we but we pretty much but um
so we wanted to try out themes like just
different things as we're going through
the show as you're going through 1100
episodes you might just be like let's
try some new [ __ ] yeah just to see if
people like some new shoes just to give
our fans more [ __ ] twists and
different things when they come back
from Orange but that's cool they even in
all these [ __ ] episodes they still
care about us and they still add a
little extra on top of trying this new
thing so we know our demo a lot of our
demo definitely [ __ ] smokes weed
first so we're like yo last minute
episode based around this and me and
Chanel smoke Rob don't smoke but me and
Chanel smoke so you know we come on show
we think certain things are funny and
[ __ ] we don't smoke uh during episodes I
smoke sometimes now like during like at
my lunch break or something else and
um but you know try not to get too
[ __ ] stoned we kicking it yeah and
you got to be on point and [ __ ] like you
said sometimes I get slow
you got to be on your [ __ ] yeah for sure
no well sure for sure you're outside
there's got to be the best set
it's just the way I don't know if just
as if you were like Rosie went to the
table my girl my girlfriend's been to
the taping all three times yeah oh it's
funny because we haven't taken down like
it's probably three four years years now
I mean we haven't taped with uh audience
in like three years now it's been a long
time because of covet and then from
there we kind of just being honest we
were just like this is easier and this
is we get three even more jokes and
crazier jokes because with the audience
we kind of had to to train the show to
kind of be more of our sense of humor
later on in Seasons because with the
audience the audience kind of trains you
on what you can get away with and sense
of humor you know what I'm saying
because the audience reacts a certain
way and they kind of dictate Vibes and
movements so you're like okay this
audience doesn't like this kind of joke
or this audience just now we don't have
any of that so we just [ __ ] watch it
yeah we're just talking a whole bunch of
[ __ ]
and that and now yeah and now MCV has
kind of let the show get more mature and
more it's fun it's a little I would say
I'll say raunchier but we say it way
Wilder [ __ ] because
I think I guess we've earned that we're
just like you guys have grown with us
we're on this show still this is the
[ __ ] how we think
yeah it's fun though it's a lot of fun
do you still bring us on or is it mainly
like we have some guests on um we had
Tori putwell on today uh Toys the homie
uh but we we have few and far between
like it just depends like it's
right now it's like if somebody's a
super fan and really wants to come on
the show and they're uh
big enough on the show then they
probably can get on the show but we
don't we definitely don't have it like
we used to we used to like really we're
only doing four episodes a day but
sometimes we do all four episodes I
guess oh wow um versus now we really
keep it to maybe one guest today if we
ought to do it and uh oh that makes
sense and maybe if we are really feeling
like that we might do two guests in a
day but yeah we don't do as many guests
anymore because just because of covert
restrictions it's more [ __ ] and then
it's just like we do have a lot of fun
with just us three too it's a lot of
[ __ ] fun people do enjoy those
episodes and it doesn't really dictate
the viewership anymore so yeah it's it's
what it is
exactly exactly well no
um thank you for being here man I know
we got to get you guys man I know you're
you're uh hurting right now I could my
bad I know you've been sitting for a
while it's kind of like a new a new
injury and [ __ ] I'm sorry I do got some
[ __ ] for you though I appreciate it you
can take this home all right this is uh
my brand
yeah it's the orange Billboards I don't
know if you've seen by LAX but it's it's
me getting high on it so it's uh pens
Edibles pre-rolls uh the Edibles are
strong as hell I appreciate it
how strong I would uh take half of one
and then and then see how you feel at
home
this one thing is 100 milligrams yeah
they taste like real candy though yeah
so be safe no I'm not about to eat no
look bro I told you I'm casual as hell I
know myself I probably eat 20 of that
thing to start it's just to be safe and
then like 10 minutes 30 minutes go by
and I'm like I ain't that high I might
go for 40. but I ain't going higher than
40. I don't trust myself well there you
go man we'll smoke it up I know you're
you're hurting right now so fall asleep
man those shits Are Gonna Knock You Out
I appreciate it appreciate it uh we're
getting ready to find you on social
media uh and Steelo Brim I think yeah
and then I just got a tick tock yeah
s-t-e-e-l-o-b-r-i-m I just got Tick Tock
that one is real Steelo Brim yeah but
you know hit me if you want to Spotify
Apple music all that stuff September 9th
yeah yeah goodbye Peter and Larry June a
couple days before so yeah go check it
out on Spotify Apple music everything my
guys appreciate you man appreciate y'all
he smoked it up the whole time I
appreciate it
man I switched it up I started smoking
this from this uh 22 red it's shirt
lotto and [ __ ]
I smoke ogs all day but it's just been
getting me kind of goofy High okay I'm
not just tired I feel like I was like
giggly and [ __ ] so it's a good day man I
appreciate you for smoking thank you for
hanging out with us thank you so much
Marty we're good you guys good
appreciate your favorite episodes this
has been the dope as usual podcast guys
thank you so much for being here have a
dope ass day wow I'm high as hell my
hair looks like
I'm highest this is a visual
representation of me
[Music]
perfect